MICAH BAKER: Hello, and
welcome to our session.
This session is
intended for customers
who are new to Cloud
Run for Anthos,
as well as our
existing customers who
are excited to learn
what's new in the product.
I'm excited to walk us
through our agenda today,
including a demo of the
new capabilities of Cloud
Run for Anthos that
we'll explore later
in the presentation.
I'm Micah Baker, Product Manager
for Cloud Run for Anthos,
and I'm joined by my
colleague, Jeenal.
JEENAL SHAH: Hi, I'm Jeenal
Shah, Engineering Manager
at Google Cloud.
My focus is building
simplified developer experience
on Managed and Hybrid
Serverless Compute Platforms.
I'm very excited
to share updates
on Cloud Run for Anthos.
We have been focused on
bringing Cloud Run for Anthos
to all Anthos platforms.
Micah?
MICAH BAKER: Yeah, I think
for a lot of the customers who
are new to Cloud Run
for Anthos, maybe we
should give a little
bit of background
on what is Cloud Run for
Anthos, what makes it special,
and maybe some of
the building blocks.
Could you tell us a
little bit about Knative?
JEENAL SHAH: Yes, absolutely.
So Cloud Run for Anthos is
built on top of Knative.
What is Knative?
Knative is an
open-source platform
with a very strong
community that
brings built-in
learnings from Google
and many other companies.
So what values does it bring?
So Kubernetes is a raw power.
It's a ubiquitous platform, but
it's not easy for developers.
Knative was initial step,
adding convenience and tooling
built on top of Kubernetes.
It provides a
developer-centric API
to stand up scalable, secure,
stateless services in seconds.
On top of that, you run Knative
anywhere Kubernetes runs,
so you never have to worry
about vendor lock in.
So, Micah.
MICAH BAKER: Yeah, I love
that explanation of Knative.
Thanks so much, Jeenal.
I think of Cloud
Run for Anthos as
like the Google-supported
managed Knative.
It allows us to give all the
power of Kubernetes that you
mentioned, as well as
the benefits of Knative,
but further create ease of
use, add more features to it,
and bring that Google support.
So it also makes
it possible for us
to use part of the Anthos
Ecosystem as needed.
For example, we use
Anthos Service Mesh now,
which is our managed version
of open-source Istio.
Also because of Anthos, we can
deploy Cloud Run for Anthos
anywhere that Anthos Service
Mesh can be installed.
So it gives us a
lot of flexibility
and enables these hybrid
and multicloud deployments
that our customers
have been asking for.
But Jeenal, can you
tell us a little bit
about how the
developer experience
in Cloud Run for
Anthos relates back
to that Knative building block?
JEENAL SHAH: Yes, absolutely.
So what we are doing here is we
are delivering all the powers
of Kubernetes along with
developer-focused features
of Knative, but without
making developers
learn either technology.
Cloud Run for Anthos abstracts
all the complex details
of platform, enabling developers
to focus on what matters--
that is, writing code and
building applications.
Micah?
MICAH BAKER: That's a
really great outcome
for our developers,
that they don't
have to become Kubernetes
experts or Knative experts.
They can just focus on
development velocity.
So I think that's a really
good background on what
Cloud Run for Anthos is.
Maybe before we continue,
just a quick pit
stop into what is Anthos and
how that Anthos stack actually
enables these outcomes
for developers.
So I'll just explain a
little bit about Anthos
as an abstraction of Kubernetes.
So Anthos is a
Kubernetes platform
that can run on Google Cloud.
It can run on-prem
and it can also
run on other Cloud
providers and still
have a single pane of
glass for a platform team
to manage that infrastructure.
And then Cloud Run
for Anthos runs
on top of Anthos,
further abstracting
Kubernetes from the developers.
So it creates a
separation of concerns--
platform teams
care about Anthos,
that's the platform they
run, and then the developers
care about Cloud Run for
Anthos because that's
their lens that
they see the Cloud
and on-prem
infrastructure through.
Jeenal, could you
explain a little bit
about how it works
for a developer?
A little bit about what their "a
day in the life of a developer"
would be?
JEENAL SHAH: Absolutely,
and I'm happy to share
what all features Cloud Run for
Anthos comes out of the box.
Cloud Run for Anthos is tightly
integrated with Cloud Builder
and under the covers uses
industry-standard Cloud-native
specification that allows you
to build applications directly
from source code and deploy.
You can also directly
deploy your Docker
containerised applications.
You don't need to learn
kubectl or Knative commands.
It is directly integrated with
G-Cloud CLI or Google Cloud
Platform UI.
The other features that I
am really passionate about
is talking about gradual
rollouts, rollbacks,
and traffic
migrations, and why I'm
so excited because it
brings out of the box
Google's SRE's best practices.
Cloud Run for Anthos
allow you to roll out
new revisions of your
applications or services
you perform with
simple A/B testing,
canary testing by specify
which revision should receive
what percentage of traffic.
It allows you to roll back
to our previous versions
gradually throughout
your revision,
or split traffic between
multiple revisions.
And with this, you can
directly either use
our continuous deployment or
integrate that with your CI/CD.
It also comes tightly integrated
with Cloud Monitoring and Cloud
Logging out of the box.
It provides a metrics
collection dashboard
so that you can gain visibility
into your performance
availability, health of your
services, and infrastructures.
Because it uses an
OpenTelemetry agent,
it is possible to
also send metrics
to any compatible third
party monitoring solutions.
So we have some
amazing features that
comes right out of the box.
And, yeah, we will see
some of this during a demo.
Over to you, Micah.
MICAH BAKER: Well,
thanks, Jeenal.
I love that
developer experience,
and especially the focus
on it works out of the box,
but there are also
ways to customize.
And I think that really
leads well into what's
in it for the platform team.
The platform teams
get all the benefits
of Kubernetes and the
standards that it brings.
It's just such a rich
ecosystem for platform teams
using Kubernetes.
They can take advantage of
the hardware customization
through Kubernetes,
but not have to worry
about exposing that
complexity to the developers.
There's lots of ways
to configure and manage
Kubernetes and make sure
that clusters are conforming
to policies, but we
don't need to expose
any of the YAML and other
configuration scripts
to the developers.
So thanks to Anthos
and Kubernetes,
it's possible for the platform
teams to target workloads
wherever you need them.
There might be latency-sensitive
applications that
need to be very
close to customers,
and so you might use a
mix of different providers
to make sure that you have
your workloads running as close
to your users as possible.
But the developers don't
have to think about, oh, am I
deploying my workload
in the correct provider?
They just say, I'm
deploying my workload,
and it can go automatically
to the correct places.
So I think that
the platform team
gets a full separation
of the concerns
so that they can
focus on the platform.
And then the developer
team, the application team
gets to have a
separation of concerns
so they can focus on
just the application
logic and increasing
developer velocity,
doing lots more A/B testing,
and handling those rollbacks
that you talked about, which
sounds really exciting.
I think it's a really
good time for us
to give a demo of
some of these things
we've been talking about.
So I'd like to switch
us over to some
of these new features showing
you what's possible now
that Cloud Run for
Anthos can be deployed
on even more destinations
throughout Anthos.
So let's take a look.
So we have several
different Anthos clusters
to showcase the hybrid
and multi-cloud deployment
capabilities of
Cloud Run for Anthos.
The platform team has
already benefited from Anthos
by making it possible to
run these GKE clusters
across clouds and on-prem.
So let's look at the
second half of our story
to see what the
developer and operator
experience is on top of that.
Our demo starts just
as we're finishing
rolling out the blue revision
of our blue green app.
And we just have
one last cluster
to deploy to, which is
the GKE on AWS cluster,
and that will complete
the initial rollout.
So we're doing things
manually for demo purposes,
but all of the things
you're going to see here
would be part of
continuous deployment
if this were a
production workload.
So that means that
these services
could be deployed to
all of the clusters
simultaneously as part of
your delivery pipeline.
So let's get started by
clicking this Create Service
button, where we
can manually select
a target for the service.
In this case, we're going to
select that GKE on AWS cluster.
We'll leave the
namespace as default.
We'll call it the same
service as before.
We'll deploy the
blue app revision.
And I'm also going to set the
minimum number of instances
to 1.
That way this starts
right away and we
have an app that we can view
as soon as it's deployed.
I'm going to click Create.
And now it's pulling down
that container image.
JEENAL SHAH: So the app
URL at the top, Micah,
if you can highlight that.
Yep, so that app
you URL at the top
is using the IP address
of Anthos Service Mesh
ingress gateway with a
simple DNS reflection service
to provide a quick
way to test apps.
But for production,
our customers
would use their
own custom domain.
So, Micah, can you talk about
the domain a little bit?
MICAH BAKER: Yeah, I appreciate
that call out, Jeenal.
The services deployed
by Cloud Run for Anthos
have this format that
you'll see consistently.
So it's broken up like this.
First, you see the service name.
In this case, it's
blue green app.
And then you'll see the
namespace that we deployed to,
which is default. And then
the last part of the URL
is whatever your
domain would be.
So for production use, you
would have some actual domain
name mapped here.
And there's a setting for
you to tell your clusters
that all services deployed
should use your domain
and not the IP address
that we're using here.
But this is a quick and easy
thing to do for demo purposes.
Imagine this being replaced
with your own domain name
if you're deploying
this in the production.
So it looks like our
app is rolled out.
Let's click on that URL
and see what happened.
This is the first
launch of the pod,
so it'll go through that Anthos
Service Mesh ingress gateway
that we set up and
access that blue revision
of the blue green app
that we just deployed.
And if everything is good,
we'll see a blue app.
And here it is.
The blue app is up and
running and everything
looks good from an
end user perspective.
So I'll close this,
and we'll go back here.
So now that we've rolled
out the initial revision
that we were targeting,
which was the blue app,
we can go back to
our services list,
and we see that
all of our clusters
for hybrid and multi-cloud now
have this initial revision.
But now we want to do an A/B
test with our green app, which
is the cutting edge, new app
in our blue green app product.
And we're just going to jump
back to our GKE cluster.
And it's just
starting this process
of deploying a
new service again.
But this time, we're going to
click this Edit and Deploy New
Revision button at the top.
Since we have an existing
service already deployed,
we're going to tell
Cloud Run for Anthos
that we'd like to
add something to it.
So in this case, we already had
the blue app container image.
I'm going to replace that with
the green app container image.
And is there anything else
I need to change, Jeenal?
JEENAL SHAH: Yeah, so
let's make sure to disable
automatic rollout so
we can use traffic
splitting for granular
control of the traffic
to a new revision.
MICAH BAKER: OK.
JEENAL SHAH: That's the one.
MICAH BAKER: Right here.
So, yeah, we want to start
off with 0% traffic to this
since our intent is an A/B test.
That will say,
create this revision,
but we're not going to
serve anything, right?
JEENAL SHAH: Correct.
MICAH BAKER: All
right, let's deploy.
And now it's grabbing
that container image.
OK, so that looked easy.
We can use this
Manage Traffic button
to control the traffic split.
And notice that
we're already serving
100% from the initial revision,
which was our blue app.
Jeenal, what do you
recommend for this demo
versus what we would do in
production for this traffic
split?
JEENAL SHAH: Yeah,
so to make it easier
to see the traffic splitting
at work, let's go with 50%
to each revision.
What do you think?
MICAH BAKER: That sounds good.
Oh, yeah, look at that.
I changed the new one to 50%
and automatically balanced
out the percentages.
50-50 is great because for demo
purposes of the blue green app
that we're doing, that
will make it really easy
to see the traffic split.
JEENAL SHAH: Yeah.
Yeah, and for the
production, of course,
we wouldn't recommend
that, and would instead
follow the Google
SRE best practices
for the class of application
and potentially plan a five day
gradual rollout
that begins with 1%,
and then graduates daily
to a larger percentage.
MICAH BAKER: I
appreciate the call
out to Google SRE
best practices, which
we are certainly not
following in this demo
if we jump straight to 50% if
this was production traffic.
But this will be a great
way for us to just showcase
this traffic splitting.
So let's see what happened.
I'm going to open up the app.
And look, we already
got the green app.
I'm going to refresh.
And look at that.
The first refresh switched
me to the blue app.
So both of them are
running, and it's just
alternating between
the two as it randomly
does a 50% split for
any incoming requests.
So that's a pretty
quick and easy way
to do any kind of A/B tests.
Let's go back here then.
Jeenal, what do you think we
should do next since we-- it
looks to me from an end user
perspective like the 50% split
is working.
Is there anything else that
you would want to check?
JEENAL SHAH: Yeah, so
let's look at the metrics
and log to confirm that what
we see here, we like it,
and then progress the rollout.
Yeah.
MICAH BAKER: So I just jumped
right to a one hour view
since that makes
sense to me of what
we've just been working on.
Yeah.
JEENAL SHAH: Yeah, and
can we also quickly--
or, Micah, can you
quickly tell me
before we go to a
different tab here that,
how am I seeing these metrics?
MICAH BAKER: I wish
that I could claim
that I built this
dashboard myself,
but I actually am happier
to say that this was just
something that's
built into the product
and it works out of the box.
So I could do custom
metrics and logging,
but this is actually Cloud
Monitoring and Cloud Logging
working right out of the box.
So pretty convenient for
I can just immediately see
these key details of my apps.
JEENAL SHAH: Yeah, and it
has all the basic metrics,
like you said, Micah.
That looks great.
Next, can we jump
quickly at logs?
And I want to see how
my green app is doing
and if I see any error or not.
MICAH BAKER: It looks like it's
giving us success on the most
recent deployment of this.
JEENAL SHAH: So it seems like
there are no obvious issues.
So let's progress the rollout
to the green app to 100%.
MICAH BAKER: OK.
That sounds good.
So I'm using that same
Manage Traffic button
that I used before.
We're going to just
type in 100 here.
And it automatically
takes the blue app to 0.
So I'm just going to click Save.
Did my changes.
And, yeah, looks
like that's done.
Let's go back.
Let's go verify this.
This should no longer show blue.
So if I refresh, I expect--
yeah, now it's green.
I'll refresh a few more times.
I'm getting nothing but green.
It's super green.
OK, that looks like
a success to me.
That was a really
fun experience.
I didn't even have to
be a Kubernetes ninja
to do any of this.
I was able to just
use this interface
to accomplish my goals
and not really think
about the Kubernetes part of it.
JEENAL SHAH: Yep, so
that's the experience
we are targeting the Cloud
Run for Anthos, Micah.
And it's possible to break a
glass and customize things,
but it's also a great
experience right out of the box.
MICAH BAKER: That's great.
So the platform team
gets all this value
from Anthos at the
platform level,
and the application team
gets this additional value
from Cloud Run for Anthos
at the application level.
That sounds like a
pretty great combination.
That concludes the demo.
If you'd like to learn more
about Cloud Run for Anthos,
please visit any of
the links listed here.
We're excited to help both
our existing customers
and new customers continue
their journey into Kubernetes
with Anthos and
Cloud Run for Anthos.
It's been my pleasure
to talk to you
and have this discussion about
the exciting new features
in Cloud Run for Anthos.
Also, thank you so much, Jeenal,
for sharing this time with me.
JEENAL SHAH: Thank you, Micah.
And thank you,
viewers, for tuning in.
I hope you enjoy the
rest of your next 2021.
Thank you.